you're at a Crossroads and you go One
Direction or another and there's an old
blues idea that you meet the devil at
the crossroads at midnight and then you
might ask well why do you meet the devil
at the crossroads and the answer is most
fundamentally because when you come to a
place in your life where you have to
make a choice you aim up or down and so
you know you're called upon to to take
the lessons that you've been taught in a
university like this that that teaches
you to abide by the Eternal verities to
sacrifice your own narrow pretensions in
the highest sense to something that's
truly better you're a particularized
creature as a Son of God or a daughter
of god let's say you have something to
bring into the world that no one else
can bring in
and so if you fail in that Duty then you
deprive the world of that
and so you could say at the end of your
life oh my God that was so hard
it was worth it
so that's the choice you make at the
crossroads